Wo sollen wir nur hin, wenn es selbst in Deutschland
im Sommer unerträglich heiß wird?
Im Süden wird es jedenfalls noch heißer.
Beispiel Indien: Hier wird die Dürre immer
dramatischer: Die fünf Millionenstadt Chennai
hat kein Wasser mehr.
Aber noch mehr: Insgesamt 330 Millionen Menschen
sind dort von der Wasserknappheit betroffen.
Und auch hier in Deutschland droht 120.000
Menschen in Ostwestfalen schon jetzt der Wassernotstand.
Ist das der Anfang vom Ende?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Es spricht einiges dafür, dass diese extremen
Wetterereignisse mit dem Klimawandel zusammenhängen.
Das Problem: Konkrete Wettereignisse kann
man eigentlich meist nicht dem Klimawandel
zuordnen.
Allerdings passieren immer Unwetter oder Stürme,
die zumindest statistisch inzwischen deutlich
wahrscheinlicher geworden sind und vor allem
gehen damit immer größere Mengen Wasser
aus uns nieder.
Es ist also nicht nur die Bodenversiegelung
mit Straßen, Häusern und Gewerbegebieten,
die das Wasser immer schlechter abfließen
lassen.
Es regnet oder hagelt tatsächlich mehr Wasser
auf uns nieder.
Und dafür gibt es hier in Europa einen einfachen
Grund: Die Arktis verliert immer mehr Eis
vor allem im Sommer und so sind immer größere
Flächen eisfrei und damit wird das Wasser,
weil es deutlich weniger Sonnenlicht als Eis
reflektiert, wärmer.
So verdunsten so riesige Mengen an Wasser,
die jetzt als Regen oder Hagel in bisher fast
unbekannten Mengen auf uns niederprasseln.
Und auch die Hitzewelle dieses Jahr wird mit
dem Klimawandel in Verbindung gebracht.
Nachdem Mojib Lativ, führender deutscher
Klimaexperte, bisher diese Zusammenhänge
immer wieder in Frage stellte, ist er inzwischen
überzeugt, dass hier ein viel deutlicherer
Zusammenhang besteht.
Was aber auch den Extremereignissen liegt.
Der Professor des Helmholtz-Zentrums für
Ozeanforschung hat in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten
den Trend zu Temperaturen über 30 Grad in
den Sommermonaten festgestellt.
Im Speigel sagte er: "Das ist ein deutliches
Zeichen, dass die menschengemachte Erderwärmung
das Wetter beeinflusst" Sprich: Genau diesen
Sommer und diese Hitzewelle kann man nicht
zweifelsfrei dem Klimawandel zuschreiben.
Die Häufung allerdings schon und wie hoch
die Wahrscheinlichkeit für dieses Wetterereignis
im Zusammenhang mit dem Klimawandel ist auch.
Dafür gibt es sogar einen eigenen und neuen
Wissenschaftsbegriff: Die „Zuordnungswissenschaft“
- „Attribution Science“.
Hierbei geht es ganz konkret darum herauszufinden
welchen Zusammenhang es zwischen Wetter und
Klima geht.
Gearbeitet wird daran am Enviromental Change
Institute in Oxford.
Hier ist man in der Lage jedem Wetterereignis
auch den Anteil und die Wahrscheinlichkeit
des Zusammenhangs mit dem Klimawandel zuzuordnen.
Für den Wahnsinnssommer im letzten Jahr mit
einer erstmals seit der Wettererfassung komplett
warmen Nordhalbkugel wurde von dem Institut
eine deutlich höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit in
Zusammenhang mit dem Klimawandel errechnet.
Konkret war die Wahrscheinlichkeit für die
hohen Temperaturen in Zusammenhang mit dem
Klimawandel fünfmal höher.
Möglich wird das durch den Vergleich der
verschiedenen Klimamodelle in einer Welt ohne
den menschengemachten Klimawandel und mit
ihm.
Dabei werden Simulationen gegen das Wetterereignis
gestellt, das untersucht wird.
Dabei werden Unmengen an Daten erfasst und
mit speziellen Algorithmen durchgerechnet,
die die deutsche Leiterin des Instituts Klimawissenschaftlerin
und Physikerin Friederike Otto mitentwickelt
hat.
Sie sagt zu dem Verfahren: "Zum ersten Mal
in der Geschichte verfügen wir über die
Mittel, um belastbare Aussagen über einzelne
Wetterereignisse zu treffen."
Das Zitat stammt aus ihrem Buch: „Wütendes
Wetter“ Mit ihrer Methode wird, so Otto
"die Klimawissenschaft gewissermaßen vom
Kopf auf die Füße" gestellt.
Und es eröffnet ganz neue rechtliche Perspektiven.
Zum ersten Mal kann Wetter kausal mit dem
Klimawandel in Zusammenhang gebracht werden.
Und da ziemlich exakt bekannt ist wer wieviel
in welcher Weise zum Klimawandel beiträgt
können die Verantwortlichen wie Ölkonzerne,
Regierungen, Stromkonzerne wie RWE undsoweiter
undsofort.
Da ja alle im Wissen und der Kenntnis der
Auswirkung ihres Tuns handeln dürfte es grobe
Fahrlässigkeit sein, die hier zum Tragen
kommt.
Das heißt Angela Merkel und die Chefs der
Konzerne dürften auch persönlich haften.
Das wird im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ein
langer Prozess, aber man kann nur hoffen,
dass er gerecht wird.
Laut Frederike Otto werden solche Klagen bereits
mit ihren Daten vorbereitet.
Ihr habt euch entschieden und wollt einen
Kanal zum Thema Natur und Umwelt.
Das habt ihr unter dem Video „…“ kommentiert.
Wir
werden ihn machen.
Wer hat Lust mitzumachen?
Schreibt an info@unitedcreators.net.
Wir brauchen Moderatorinnen, Moderatoren,
Leute die recherchieren, die schreiben usw.
Ich freue mich auf eure Rückmeldung!
Hier geht es weiter mit …. Anklicken, anschauen
und … abonnieren!